وبموازاة
على قرار مسانده الشعب الفلسطيني واشار
الى ان جماعه الحوثييين مستمره في تنفيذ
قرار منع الملاحه الاسرائيليه او المتجهه
الى موانئ فلسطين المحتله في
البحرين الاحمر والعربي حتى وقف العدوان
ورفع الحصار عن الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه انضموا الينا من الحديده مراسلنا سمير
النمري سمير المزيد من الاضاءه عما
يجري نعم هذه هذا الاستهداف ياتي في ظل
تصعيد كبير تقوم به جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين خلال الاسابيع الماضيه تجلى اكثر
خلال هذا الاسبوع من خلال عمليات استهداف
لسفن امريكيه وبريطانيه في منطقه خليج عدن
وهي مناطق بعيده او جنوبيه اليمن هذا
الاستهداف الذي تم واعلنه الناطق العسكري
باسم انصار الله الحوثيين هذا اليوم انه
تم استهداف سفينه عسكريه امريكيه كانت
تقدم الدعم اللوجستي للقوات الامريكيه في
خليج عدن وتم استهدافها بصاروخ بحري مناسب
بحسب تعبير الناطق العسكري هذا الاستهداف
ياتي بعد يوم واحد فقط من اعلان انصار
الله الحوثيين استهداف سفينه
بريطانيه نفطيه كانت ايضا تبحر في خليج
عدن وادت الى هذا الاستهداف الى احتراقها
كما انه ياتي بعد ايام فقط من م ما قاله
الناطق العسكري للجماعه بان عمليه حدوث
اشتباك حدثت مع القوات الامريكيه في منطقه
خليج عدن واستمرت لساعتين رغم النفي
الامريكي المتواصل لعمليات الاستهداف هذه
مجمل هذا التصعيد ياتي بعد اعلان الزعيم
الجماعه عبد الملك الحوثي بان بان صواريخ
جديده دخلت الى الخدمه وان على الامريكي
بحسب وصفه ان يعي جيدا ان ما قبل استهداف
السفن الامريكيه لن يكون بعده في اشاره له
الى ان العدوان او ما يسميه العدوان
الامريكي البريطاني على اليمن لا يمكن ان
يمر ان يمر دون رد من قبل انصار الله
وانهم جاهزون لاستهداف السفن وكذلك
المدمرات والبوارج الامريكيه الموجوده
سواء في البحر الاحمر او في خليج عدن خلال
هذا التصعيد ايضا الذي تقوم به جماعه
انصار الله كان هناك ايضا قصف امريكي
وبريطاني على عدد من المواقع العسكريه في
اليمن من بينها الحديده وكذلك تعز
والبيضاء وصنعاء ولكن انصار الله دائما ما
كانوا يقللوا من اهميه هذه الضربات مؤكدين
بانها تستهدف معسكرات مخلاه وانه لا يوجد
تاثير لهذه الضربات الجويه على قدرات
العسكريه للجماعه وانها مستمره في استهداف
كل السفن الامريكيه والبريطانيه ردا على
ما قالت انه عدوانه على اليمن وكذلك ايضا
السفن المتوجهه لاسرائيل في اطار مسانده
غزه شكرا جزيلا لك سمير النمري كنت معنا
من
الحديده